thank you so this is work in progress it
was originally planned to be a complete
work but unfortunately we didn't make
enough progress so it's working progress
this is going with my student guide dog
and one of the ways that it work in
progress is this work has no application
what I mean by that I got no sliders
head here are all the applications this
is this is our rhythmic work where we
hope that the problems we're thinking
about are suitably general that they
will fit the number of possible
applications but again we sort of
started with the algorithms and see what
consequence is that so the starting
point of this is are these data
structures that have been developed in
the computer science community forum
sketches and you know these sketching
ideas connect deeply with with lots of
other topics that people are interested
in they connect to press sensing they
connect to you and also known as random
projections so i should say what i mean
by sketch i'm thinking of ways of taking
a large amount of data probably for the
most part h i'm going to think of is
represented by a high dimensional vector
and i'm going to come up with some more
compact representation of it that i will
think of primarily as a linear
transformation so no they're going to
take my day to x i'm going to apply some
sketching transformation to that data
and I'll get some summary that i'll call
the sketch of these eggs i'm going to be
interested in transformations that i can
write where s is
a matrix some structured but random
matrix why do I want to think about this
restricted class of objects were couple
reasons one they come with you know nice
properties so as soon as as soon as I
talk about linear transformations then I
get the property that I can take two
pieces of data x and y combine them
scale them up till now and the sketch of
a linear combination of XY is the
corresponding linear combination of the
sketches so this again you're talking
rather strategy is is my so around about
way of saying this is something is going
to suit data that's very large so I'm
actually processing it in different
places and combining the sketch stories
it's got a suit data where I built a
summary of everything I've seen so far
and then either some new unit of data
also uses a lot of data arrives I want
to update my summary of it it's also
interesting because sketches exists that
we know lots of constructions of
particular matrices as the capture
various properties of vectors that are
suitably foundational that they're
useful to us
so sometimes we'll think about sketches
in terms of this sort of linear
transformation terminology sometimes
more computationally more thing from in
terms of hash functions because if I do
think that X is so fast and high
dimensional that I would never want to
store it explicitly then for sure s also
has that characteristic so I never want
to think of really materializing s
explicitly I want to think of drawing
columns of s or rows of x1 I need it so
those columns or rows are going to be
describing to have the cash functions
that are compact and easy to kind of
essentially materialize individual
entries of the sketch matrix on demand
I'm now from now on I'm really going to
treat these sketches of black box
because we don't need to know too much
about them the property of sketches i'm
going to use today is i'm going to use
the fact that there's a particular there
are particular sketch constructions that
allow me to estimate vector in a product
right so if I build a sketch of vector X
and a sketch of vector Y I can combine
those two sketches and get an estimate
of what's the inner product of x and y
and these are compact so they're kind of
essentially independent of the dimension
of the input vectors what do I mean by
that i mean you know if i if i choose my
sketch size to look something
proportional to 1 over epsilon squared
for a parameter epsilon then i'm going
to estimate this in a product with
additive error so whatever the answer is
plus or minus some error that looks like
epsilon times the product of the two
norms okay so that's the black box
that's the assumption about sketches
that I'll be using and what I'm going to
talk about today is an attempt to sort
of take that black box and build on top
of that a more complex data structure a
more complex algorithm that lets us
study correlations
what do I mean by correlations I mean
exactly what you think of when I talk
about correlations I mean you know you
have some serious series of data to
series of data you know to something
let's say something that will give you
some x values and they'll give you some
corresponding Y values and you want to
say you know is there a linear
relationship between these so you can
have no end of fun looking up this web
page of spirit correlations that's
essentially taken large quantities of
data and gone through many pairs and
seen when is there a very high
correlation between things for which it
would be hard to posit any causal
relationship so this is when I picked
out it's showing total revenue generated
by entertainment arcades versus computer
science doctorates awarded in the US and
you'll see you know the two series seem
to travel together pleasingly closely
okay so the problem i'm trying to think
about here is to say let's say I've got
a very large collection of time series
and so very many time series in each
time series is very high dimensional and
I want to pull out which are the highly
correlated pairs rather than looking for
spirit correlations I would rather find
meaningful correlations is I'm going to
hope that what i find is meaningful okay
so let's introduce some symbols m is the
number of observations m is suitably
large and n is the number of time series
n is also suitably large and we might
think about doing this you know if my
concession to real time is to say that
well maybe we're seeing new observations
of these so this is not a static fixed
data set this is a growing data set you
know so you know if you want to start
dreaming about applications you can
think of you know telecommunications
networks or global scale data centers or
whatever else seems like it might
generate lots of data
so what do I need to do here when I'm
looking for correlations I'm thinking
the time series are sort of essentially
being drawers of random variables the
covariance is a first attempt to capture
the interrelation of two series and
that's basically you know I'd like to
look at a quantity based on the
expectation the product minus the
product of the expectations and the
correlation is just an appropriately
normalized version of the covariance
right so all I'm interested in is for
any given pair being able to pull out
the correlation of that pair and given
you an actual data I can just you know
plug in and compute so if time was not
an issue space was not an issue i just
wanted to do this computation what would
I do well one plausible thing would be I
would for each input series I would
create some appropriately normalized
version of it so essentially subtract
off the mean of the series and then
divide through by the standard deviation
and so that lets me then reduce to in a
product because the correlation between
any pair is just the inner product
between the corresponding vector
representations
and what's wrong with with doing the
exact thing you need this pre-processing
this normalization takes time portion
from the number of series times the
number of observations well nothing
wrong with that that is you know that is
the size of the input so if I'm prepared
to look at all the input then I'm going
to incur that kind of cost but what
hurts is this kind of search right and
you know this is not unique to this
problem lots of other problems run into
this quadratic bottleneck where you're
essentially trying to compare all pairs
and if you do explicitly compare all
pairs you hit an N squared term times m2
actually you know run through those
entries so I might I might be able to
squeeze this a little bit if I start
thinking this is a matrix computation I
have an appropriate fast matrix
multiplication algorithm that might you
know gently reduce some of these terms
but I'm not I'm not significantly going
to win here
and you know again if I can but if I
believe that n is sufficiently large to
make this painful then n squared is
definitely going to grow faster than I'd
like it to so why might we hope to do
anything better so certainly if there's
a reasonable chance that any given pair
is correlated some constant chance that
any given pair is correlated then I'm
pretty much going to and I want to
report all of those correlated pairs
then I'm just going to have to incur
something essentially quadratic so I'm
going to be thinking about situations
where most things are uncorrelated most
things are sort of randomly you know
unrelated even if it may be the
correlator you can come true that's just
a correlative things in yeah so I'd need
to introduce some extra structure so
yeah maybe odd I'd actually have some
sort of hierarchy over the series and
try to sort of relate them but in this
in a sort of base version I I don't know
a meaningful way to describe such
clusters but yeah I mean lots and lots
of variations are possible here okay so
I have a hammer my hammer is called
sketching I will apply to this problem
and see how far it gets me so the first
thing you think of doing is say well
I've already said that the basic thing
that I'm interested in a vector in a
product sketches give me that with some
noise so i can take every series you
know x1 through xn apply the sketching
transformation to each one and reduce
the dimensionality hopefully so I've
still got n objects but there now of
dimension be does that make difference
not hugely all right so
I've knocked down the coefficient on the
quadratic term hope so I've knocked it
down if I've not done this carefully I
might have inadvertently pushed it up
but hopefully I've knocked it down but I
haven't beaten this quadratic term right
because all i've done is i've reduced
the cost of comparing any pair but i
haven't reduced the number of pairs or
number of pairwise comparisons that i
would do yeah we're to think of em as as
being large certainly I mean it could be
M could be comparable to n if M is very
small than this step on help so you
might as well just work with the series
series exactly well it's essentially
essentially what what this step says is
you can kind of ignore him right and
this again it comes up a lot with
sketching that although your data
originally may have been high
dimensional essentially I mean to make
this work be casted be at least
logarithmic in end for the probabilities
work out but but because you can do this
you can kind of ignore what M was to
begin with and just assume that you're
now working with short enough sequences
okay so essentially where we have a
result of an algorithmic search problem
we want to say where are the significant
correlations so let's sort of flip
around that or that comment from earlier
that said if most things are correlated
you can't beat that if most things are
uncorrelated then there's no point
trying everything you'd like to
essentially find clusters of
uncorrelated things and say right I need
to do no further work on these clusters
so the kind of the high-level idea you'd
like to put into practice is to say let
me do some kind of clustering while the
clustering doesn't have to be at all
sophisticated it could just be
essentially simply random grouping and
the hope that will try and formalize is
to say if I sort of group a bunch of
signals together and do nothing more
sophisticated than add them up and I
take another group similarly some
together and I look at so the inner
product between those sums then if
there's no correlation of any member of
those two groups then hopefully should
be the sum should be uncorrelated and if
there is a correlation it should be
preserved
so the work to do is to take those
claims and turn the should beads into
something slightly more precise which
can be formalized without too much pain
and secondly say okay well if I do this
then for sure when I find no correlation
and I'm reasonably convinced there
really is no correlation between a pair
of groups I can ignore everything within
those groups but when there is a pair of
groups that look like there's a
correlation lurking somewhere within how
do I find it so the solution outline is
to say we're actually going to do a
couple of things you know if you kept
talking about groups so group testing
coding these kind of techniques are
going to appear and sort of an extra an
outer layer of sketching is also going
to appear this outer layer of sketching
is to do with the fact that you can
certainly imagine situations where
things combined in an unhelpful way and
a correlation that was present between
two groups cancelled out in some way so
we need to do take some steps to try and
reduce that chance and also we'll just
do enough sort of suitable random
repetitions that argue that it's
unlikely enough to happen once that will
repeat it a few times and then hopefully
catch it in one of those repetitions
so is essentially the next few slides
are just sort of taking that outline and
fleshing it out a bit more and trying to
sort of convinced that there is some
reason to hope that this approach would
work so if this is my original situation
I've got you this n equals six sequences
going in I'm looking at this sort of six
by six correlation matrix the leading
diagonal is trivially correlated but
that's mostly uninteresting what I'm
interested in are sort of off diagonal
correlations so this is trying to
represent the fact that x2 is
coordinated with x5 and it's symmetric
so what we can do is do this sort of
random bucketing grouping summation and
you know almost just putting in pictures
what I said in words we expect that
because two and five are correlated that
one and two are correlated with five and
six so essentially the fact they're sort
of zero correlation between one and five
two and six one and six doesn't hide
this and we don't find any sort of
additional spurious correlations and you
know this leak this the fact we've got
trivial correlations on the leading
diagonal this is something you know we
can predict exactly and just sort of
subtract off a contribution relying on
on to essentially sort of the fact that
everything we're doing is is linear
relationship to like great value yeah
I'm not going to say it but since you've
prompted me I will yeah I mean this is
sort of connected to surveillance work
exactly on on related problems it's it's
it's this kind of yes or trying to
identify things we're trying to see what
we can do in this realm and and how we
can sort of play around with slightly
different constructions
um
so if I do determine that sort of within
a group it looks like there's a
correlation of interest how do I decode
this is a few different approaches that
we're thinking about so that the basic
one is is to say we're going to try and
decode that by doing sort of a
within a bucket I'll do some additional
tests leaving some things out including
some things in and hope and do that in a
structure enough way based on on an
honor code so that I can sort of look at
the sequence of results interpreted
essentially as binary is this
combination still correlated is that
correlation still correlated read those
off and try and identify where the
correlation what that tells me so the
simplest way of seeing that is is when
the coding approach is a Hamming code
okay so this is sort of a much overly
simplified example so here I'm sort of
my cartoon example is if I'm thinking
about combinations of sort of individual
elements but the concept is the same so
you know here I've got the contribution
of element 1 that's small the
contribution of element to that's large
so I'd like to find it and a bunch of
contributions of other elements that are
also small so the way I might try and
use a code is basically you know I look
at the code corresponding to the binary
representation of each index that's a
basically what the Hamming code is
saying so element sort of 001 means that
in the first row i'll include the
contribution of element 1 but not in the
second or third row x 2 has a worn-in
bit position too so I'll included in the
second row but not in the first and the
last row and so on and in this carefully
constructed example that makes sure
everything works it works so the sort of
the thresholded version of Row one is
smaller than my threshold value so I
read that off as a zero the middle row
is larger than my threshold value so I
read off as one the last row is smaller
so I read it off a zero then I can
reinterpret that as an index again as
indexed to that was the heavy element so
it worked of course it works it was the
example that I chose it's not going to
work in general because of noise and
noise from sketching but also just noise
from collisions of elements things are
kind of going against
me if I really do add things up so i'm
going to start from from sort of this
baseline but try and improve it a bit
and the first improvement is to say well
actually you know I used sketching to
reduce the dimensionality of the series
but I could use sketching ideas again to
try and sort of reduce the effective of
collisions right so essentially that one
of the key techniques in sketching is
essentially sort of sparse sparse
transformations that are involved
Bernoulli random variables right emaki
variables if you like so essentially
just using plus ones and minus ones
surprisingly effective at driving down
the variant of the estimators that you
get so rather than just adding up
everything in a bucket if I associate
every entry in a bucket with a randomly
chosen plus 1 or minus 1 that means that
sort of decreases the chance that lots
of things that I don't want sum up
adversary against me sort of the
informal version so the picture here
looks like you know I'm doing my
bucketing in two rows based on to the
random partitioning and I do this sort
of multiplication by you can figure this
is a diagonal matrix if you like it's
just multiplying each row either x plus
1 or minus 1 and then also doing a
masking it's masking by either a zero
one is determined by the code that I've
chosen then some things up alright so
that's sort of the the outline of the
structure that's the outline it approach
and it's just then a question you know
the last pieces just say well exactly
what how am I going to determine those
masks
because you know here's his sort of the
real situation so I've tried to make
this cartoon a little bit more realistic
so now I'm looking at the combination of
you know something interesting coming
from row I and row j I and J are
correlated so green is sort of showing
when my mask is putting them in the same
test red or zero we're saying when
they're excluded from a test and it may
be you know again just picking some sort
of numbers to illustrate a point that my
tests mostly work but every now and then
a test will give the wrong answer so
they should have given an answer that
was greater than my test threshold so in
this case my test threshold is just half
but because of other things I'm not
shown collisions and other things going
on it may be that I get something that's
the wrong side of my test threshold so
if I were to use sort of the the Hamming
code directly and try and interpret this
I'd get erroneous conclusions I'd need
to kind of reconfigure my are needing
more repetitions to get this right but
if I have an error correcting code then
maybe I can still read this as a code
word even though essentially there is a
one or a small number of bit errors in
the code word that I decode I will still
be able to decode this as a correct
indicator of combination of I and J so
again sort of somewhat at a high level I
want to think about what codes can I put
in here that will sort of give me that
the right trade-off between essentially
the rate of error correction and the
code word length so you get to almost to
a few engineering things here all right
so because every bit I add to the code
corresponding to an extra column here
means I've got to do an extra set of
sketches for every bucket that I'm
materializing so you know those bits
really add up quickly and I can do so
that way I can do what one or two other
tricks to minimize the size of the code
that I need
so if I think about the way i allocate
and elements into the buckets i can
think of that as basically being a
permutation over the original indices
and i'll just put everything in a bucket
that shares a common prefix in its
behind your representation say well in
that case i don't actually need to code
up the prefix because everything in the
bucket has the same prefix i just need
to code up sort of the tail the suffix
of what goes into the bucket and then in
my situation I can have just stored the
random permutation explicitly and kind
of retrieve the original the indices in
the original indexing based on the the
reconstructor / muted index and the
construction of Coach that seems to work
well in that we can actually implement
it is something based on low-density
parity-check work codes and you know
that's nice it's clean it simple and it
works well with the sketches that sort
of the outline you and there's a few
there's quite a few details to kind of
fill in when you actually do this you
still get errors so you do the usual
kind of tricks that that people in
sketching and randomized algorithms do
you repeat the whole thing a few times
in parallel ISM in parallel with fresh
randomness and you sort of say not did I
find something once because maybe it's a
false positive but did I find it enough
times alright so I've got read if I see
something a lot then I'm reasonably
confident it's not a false positive and
I'm also reasonably confident that
something that really is there is I do
see often enough that it will pass this
test
okay so there's lots of a kind of clunky
proof to go through nothing nothing
particularly challenging it's just you
know setting up the right kind of random
events and showing that they all happen
with enough probability and doing sort
of the bound over all of these to say
that everything works and you know I'm
not even I'm not we're not I'm not quite
at the point where I want to sort of say
when I say sub quadratic what do I mean
it's going to be an end to the two minus
something not very big and that's also
going to rely on some possibly
optimistic assumptions so again if you
think about how am I going to make this
work I've really got to argue that the
things that are not correlated are
sufficiently not correlated that I can
put quite a few of them in the same
bucket or something that is correlated
and still be able to see that the
correlation for the trees right and to
really sort of put that in terms of N
and make that end term so quadratic you
actually need to start talking about
those correlations looking polynomial e
small as a function of n so so there is
sort of a question mark here in you know
it's certainly true in theory but how
well will it work in practice but it can
be fast I guess is the other thing that
most of the stuff that you need to do is
linear algebraic and you can kind of
bulk things together and throw it into a
fast matrix multiply so you can write it
in terms of you know whatever value of
Omega you happen to believe at the
moment so I said you know work in theory
will it work in practice this is a
question I do care about so we are we're
at the stage of proof of concept and the
concept being proved is that a smart PhD
student can write code that implements
the algorithm that is the concept I
think we've proved so far so here is you
know just a picture to try and show
what's going on here is a very small
input 50 by 50 so 50 time series of
relatively small dimension dimension a
thousand small number of sketches
someone buckets and repetitious I think
just enough that
technically it's fewer fewer tests than
if your smaller space at least and if
you represent to the data explicitly and
what this you're showing is these sort
of white dots are some planted
correlations of varying magnitude so
that is what we would like to recover
that's what the input looks like this is
sort of what you get from one iteration
of this you get you do find the things
you're looking for which is good and you
get these sort of little gray spots I
don't know how well they show up which
are things that look like they're
correlations but of small magnitude on
one iteration so you do those
repetitions in parallel and look for
what shows up consistently what shows up
consistently is what you planted there
so
proof if proof were needed that a
graduate student given time and a
reasonably powered laptop can produce
some nice pictures so what I've tried to
say today is is sort of an introduction
to this work in progress and thinking
about you know we've had sketches around
for a while and they've been very useful
for giving us you know addressing
problems that can be directly
represented as vectors finding heavy
items in vectors finding you know how
many nonzero entries there are in a
vector and so on which in turn actually
have kept people in Silicon Valley quite
entertained you know there's a small
industry in Silicon Valley of people at
Google and Facebook implementing these
kind of algorithms for analyzing their
log data and seeing what their customers
are doing so the interest to me is to
say you know how far can we go with this
can we look at more complex structures
again you if you connect to that line of
work on randomized numerical linear
algebra that's basically you know
sketching in one form this is sort of
similarly in that vein so there's lots
of other sort of sketching techniques
that I won't talk about today not in
this talk but you know do ask me about
those so it you know what I'm really
sort of trying to do so you know we have
these techniques we have reasonable
facility with them that we can play
around with them put them together cart
with new algorithms and in in the
context of this workshop I think the
question is does this get us anywhere
does this get us close enough to having
a conversation with the people that have
the real data that they might want to
think about any of these techniques so
with that question I will finish and
turn it over to you for answers thank
you
can you do anything special when the
vectors are vectors of one's a negative
ones basically for hamming distance yes
sir so my my immediate answer that
question is you can't do anything more
special than what we're doing already
that I think having having that
assumption that there is nice structure
in the vectors I don't know of any
technique that takes explicit advantage
of that the advantage that I might see
is if you think about the way that we
build the sketches they are based on on
these sort of carefully structured
random transformations which also happen
to be you know essentially binary minus
one plus one or sparse with zeros in so
in terms of keeping the bit
representation small if my input is
discrete minus one plus one and my
transformation is discrete minus 1 plus
1 then for sure I don't need too many
bits to represent those products so I
sort of win a little bit in in this
little bit representation inside my
algorithm but I don't know if I can take
a more direct advantage of of that
structure so i guess the algorithm out
of thought of first problem at all is to
imagine that you peek login or so
vectors at random in equality law Kenya
hmm compute the correlation of each of
the given and
with those login factors and use that as
a kind of filter if you appeal to a
johnson lyndon strauss type
dimensionality reduction and say well
only to check the correlation of two
input sequences if the log and profile
of them are kind of close yeah randomly
chosen directions and maybe lot gets not
enough but something that was kind of
that was that's my my initial response
or anything login is enough that you can
do gluten and probably beat this right
yeah maybe that's something sort of
maybe to go back to and try it again but
I'm hesitant just because I'm trying to
state results that work over sort of
arbitrary inputs and you know I guess I
have to think about that a little bit
more but yeah there might be some other
things you can do to kind of rule some
options out but then you're going to
still be quadratic on what remains
you're sort of goodness or any hours so
yeah what'swhat's I guess you're saying
sort of take you pick pick your sort of
you know test vectors as they were run a
bunch of tests so I'm going to say ok
you know this input vector looked like
it was yeah I gotta have to have quite a
lot of them if it's going to show any
correlation because it's going to be
uncorrelated with most things so but it
Flags correlated with a subset of them
and then what are these up I guess I
pick out the things that look like
they've got an approximately overlapping
set of core ellipse Ricky and you know
as soon as you start invoking Johnson in
the Strauss I mean I I should have used
the name but this is all essentially
Johnson interest in disguise is these
sort of sketch results basically
could be related to that should I think
of your sketches in the first or second
slide isn't these need to be compact
American useful should I think of it as
like a randomized this roast um I think
of them as a low Independence Johnson in
distress so just to get you know very
technical if you think about the sparse
John Donne industrials work that gets
you to a certain level of sparsity so
firstly I guess I could say you know I'm
somewhat agnostic as to what
instantiation of sketches you choose but
you probably want something that's
sparse to keep it suitably fast so the
sparse Johnson and Strauss constructions
get you down essentially to a 1 over
epsilon sparsity there are other
constructions which I tend to use in
which are using imitations that get you
down to a constant sparsity which seems
impossible but and so the trick is it's
a structured sparsity so essentially you
do almost what I showed you in the main
part of the talk also within the
sketches you you hash out two buckets so
every every index in the original vector
goes to some bucket and what you argue
about is that you need actually only
limited independence you need
essentially for wise independence
because what you go through as you go
through sort of a expectation and
variance calculation you need very low
independence to get those to work out
but we can sort of chat more offline
about how these constructions work I
mean again for this kind of thing at one
level we just need any whether it's
Johnson in the Strauss with Gaussian
whether it's sparse Johnson in distress
whether it's these kind of hash
structured things what this will relied
on is just that you can you can do in a
product up to additive error and they
will give you that in in one form or
Ella
just all that money thing it's very
useful hmm there's the sort of thing of
you into gps races can you say it there
yeah the other thing yeah yeah I say yes
lots of knowledge at this point yes yes
coral in my ass I'm a Fraggle so within
15 minutes of you I within a mile of you
exactly so I think that's that's where
this this this gets interesting because
I can tell you this makes more
assumptions than that application would
want but and we can start to play around
with how could you make the to marry up
so this relies on a precise sort of
one-to-one matching of indexes it says
that you're lining up X I with why I and
in your application you want to sort of
line up X I plus or minus 15 minutes and
so that's that's I think where it could
get fun you say you know either can I
sort of just say am I seeing the same
trajectory at roughly the same speed but
shifted in time so you'd want to start
thinking about can I do some kind of
convolution of these right so you might
just do some pre-processing to kind of
say let's let's kind of fuss the time
and just count approximate time since 0
and riri base everything so that's a lot
of wear that's exactly where there might
be sort of some interesting new
questions to play around with it says
okay you can do this kind of thing but
when you have this kind of noise this
kind of perturbation then what happens
problem feels as if it should be very
close to nearest neighbors and high
dimensional space yes it should be
um it's not quite the same because
because of the this we're not we
essentially not in metric space but
we're close enough that that we need to
think more about those connections and
certainly there are techniques from
nearest neighbor search essentially kind
of like the sort of rejection approaches
that Sam part was talking about that
could potentially be applied here and
certainly in the fundamental issue you
want to avoid doing the explicit all
pairs can you question the data the
queries are yes I'm it's not right it's
not quite nearest neighbor but it is
sort of nearest neighbor in the sense
that people are interested in the sort
of the old pairs nearest neighbor
problem I think it's got nearest
neighbor at its heart somewhere or not
quite nearest it's all one of the tricky
things is you're looking for large
values rather than small values and that
complicates things a little bit but I
don't know that it's fundamentally
different
yes so that's that's one of the the
flexibilities we're looking to bake in
here because because the sketches are
essentially data independent you know
that you're picking the random
transformation independent of the data
you can extend this and that's that was
sort of my concession to real time at
the start I'm saying you may be seeing
the observations and you can just slop
those in very quickly to the current
current summaries you still have this
sort of relatively expensive search step
at the end sort of yes so you're in
you're into the new what the computer
scientists call sliding window and it's
very easy to remove past observations if
you can tell me what they were because I
can just subtract off their contribution
but in general you don't tend to
remember the past observations because
there's too many of them and you've
forgotten them and then you get into
this sort of you get an extra at least
logarithmic factor and probably worse
because you're sort of keeping sketches
that cover you know different fractions
and you're kind of gluing them together
to cover the window and then slotting
things around so so you can do stuff but
it adds sufficiently many logarithmic
factors that any hope you had before of
claiming that you were beating a space
found might start to disappear in
practice sorry
I'm not sure exactly what you have in
mind by discounting with because I mean
that hand up was just so good happen we
could market perhaps several of the
questions right so whereas lengths of
vectors are preserved to relative error
yes yes that's right yes completely
different ballgame so you know Jocelyn
and straws or random projections and
perhaps also the nearest neighbor or
sort of to do with lines whereas is a
spirit of birds it does I mean and and
the normally normally I sort of avoid
dot product for exactly that reason that
the nice coincidence or of structure
here is that if you're looking for large
correlation then firstly you're
normalizing to the range minus 1 to plus
1 your epsilon error is an additive
excellent error in there I'm looking for
things that are large and so if I look
something like slits like you know 20
point six point seven the sketching part
only perturbs me by sort of plus or
minus epsilon so it's one of the few
places where the fact that dot product
is not relative error preserved but his
additive error actually doesn't work
completely against me that makes sense
ten years or so thanks a lot thank you